[Music]
a given water source has its ionic
compounds listed in the provided bar
chart assume that all concentrations are
in milligram per liter as
ca3 how much lime in milligram per liter
as
cac3 must be added in order to remove
the carbonate
hardness so this is a very simple
problem but I don't blame you at all if
you don't remember your environmental
engineering 101 and need a refresher so
let's get into it let's explain the bar
chart the top bar are the catons or
positively charged ions the bottom are
the anion or negatively charged ions the
problem asks us to find the carbonate
hardness carbonate hardness is going to
be equal to the lower of the following
two numbers the total hardness and the
alkalinity so let's define these terms
next the total hardness is going to be
the sum of the calcium and
magnesium these are the only two catons
that contribute to
hardness the alkalinity is going to be
equal to the sum of the calcium and
magnesium that overlaps with the
bicarbonate if the total hardness is
less than the bicarbonate then there
cannot be any non-carbonate hardness
left over it is all carbonate
hardness if the total hardness was
greater than the bicarbonate then there
would be both carbonate hardness and
non-carbonate hardness present the point
of the bar chart is to show you how much
of the hardness from calcium and
magnesium are carbonate hardness versus
non-carbonate
hardness carbonate hardness can be
removed with the addition of chemicals
like lime non-carbonate hardness
typically requires more Advanced
treatment methods such as ion
exchange so in this problem all we have
to do to get the total hardness is sum
the calcium and the Magnesium the sodium
does not contribute to hardness and so
is
ignored however to get the answer to the
problem we have one more small step we
need to
include the question does not ask about
total hardness but rather how much lime
is needed to remove the carbonate
hardness since the carbon dioxide is
present we need to account for it with
respect to how much lime to add this is
because carbon dioxide does not
contribute to hardness either but it
does consume
lime the lime needed is going to be the
sum of the CO2 and the hardness from
calcium and magnesium or 300+ 30 from
the bar
chart if you wanted to get technical it
is 200 from the calcium 1 100 from the
magnesium and 30 from the carbon dioxide
giving us
330 I don't think there is much in the
manual related to bar charts but if you
search softening you will find some
compounds used in softening and their
molecular weights this could be useful
if the problem did not give all of the
values as milligrams per liter as
C3 and instead wanted you to calculate
them before summing them
here are how you could have gotten to
some of the incorrect answers
instead you might select 200 if you
think that calcium is the only cat I
that contributes to the lime
requirement you might select
230 if you think that calcium and carbon
dioxide are the only two contributors to
the lime
requirement and finally you might select
320 if you assume that all of the
bicarbonate
even the amount beyond the sum of the
calcium and magnesium are what
contributes to
hardness but since you've watched this
video you are aware that the amount of
lime needed is going to be the amount of
calcium and magnesium that overlaps with
the
bicarbonate plus the amount that would
be consumed by the carbon
dioxide and that's all it takes to solve
this problem if you are looking for more
information on how to calculate some of
these equations or water softening as a
whole I will link another video in the
description that I found really helpful
as
well